les dirigeants de psa sortent du silence
pour la première fois depuis l'annoncé
de la fermeture du site d'hérimoncourt
ils dévoilent leurs projets de
développement sur l'économie circulaire
nous voulons mettre les bouchées doubles
dans cette activité d'économie
circulaire donc de prendre des pièces
anciennes et de les remettre à neuf pour
les revendre à des prix très compétitifs
et nous pensons pouvoir tripler de
taille
d'abord en europe et puis après
l'exportation dans ce métier vesoul est
un centre qui fait 80 hectares avec 1700
salariés
c'est un des plus grands stockage au
monde de pièces de rechange avec un
salle informatique qui permet de livrer
des pièces partout en europe et même au
delà ce matin à la sous-préfecture de
montbéliard
ces mêmes dirigeants ont présenté leur
stratégie aux parlementaires au maire
d'hérimoncourt et au préfet du doubs la
rencontre a duré plus de deux heures et
demie les élus ont demandé à psa de
maintenir l'activité sur le site
le représentant de l'état exige quant à
lui une solution pour revitaliser la
future friche industrielle pour moi pas
moi ce que j'ai proposé c'est qu'on nous
puissions mettre en place un groupe
technique ce que psa accepté entre le
conseil régional l'état et donc le coût
psa et l'agglomération de montbéliard se
coupent techniques puissent pouvoir
creuser approfondir des vraies solutions
donc de projets industriels et pour
effectivement qu'autour de la table on
trouve une solution d'avenir industriels
le constructeur automobile tente
d'apaiser la colère des élus en
affirmant être en discussion avec des
entreprises pour qu'elles viennent se
développer à hérimoncourt une nouvelle
qui ne console pas le député frédéric
barbier
actuellement vous savez à dix neuf mille
mètres carrés qui sont consacrés
industrie il ya 200 salariés qui
travaillent et on nous propose à la
place peut-être un centre de formation
peut-être effectivement une entreprise
qui pourrait développer une activité
ils ont téléphoné chez hermès pour
savoir si hermès n'avait pas des
développements également de leur côté
les vrais développement dans le pays de
montbéliard
actuellement ils sont sur l'industrie
automobile
une réunion stratégique devrait se tenir
début mai